[Música]
es un jardín del edén en medio de
mozambique el parque de corongo sa
cuenta con una biodiversidad poco común
y cientos de especies en 4000 kilómetros
cuadrados un ecosistema único que se
volvió un lugar privilegiado para
estudios que atrae científicos del mundo
entero y uno de los mejores medios para
estudiar la fauna es observar desde las
alturas
[Música]
bueno
en este helicóptero un equipo de
especialistas en materia de conservación
de la vida salvaje esta mañana se reúnen
en el sur del parque para censar manadas
de elefantes bastan unos cuantos minutos
para ubicar a los primeros animales
aquí hay uno no tiene marcas
color
y hay otro aquí por este lado hay más
algunos paquidermos cuentan con collares
gps lo que los guardas forestales
quieren verificar es que la población de
elefantes siga creciendo también
estudian sus desplazamientos sus hábitos
para protegerlos mejor
la población aumenta
ahora tenemos mil elefantes
estamos orgullosos estamos alcanzando
nuestro objetivo y esto nos alegra
[Música]
la alegría de los ángeles guardianes de
elefantes es proporcional al horror que
golpeó el parque hace 45 años
en 1977 estalla la guerra civil
mozambique se hace pedazos y el parque
se transforma en un campo de batalla los
animales se encuentran en medio de los
combates en 15 años el 95% de la fauna
desaparece
la guerra termina a finales de 1992 y
desde entonces la vida regresa poco a
poco al parque hasta transformarse hoy
en día en una especie de laboratorio a
cielo abierto para estudiar las especies
desde el rey de la sabana hasta el
animal más minúsculo
orina vicente es una de las
conservadoras del parque en sus armarios
clasifica todos los insectos aquí
presentes
de saint es piscis todas estas son
nuevas especies y también son endémicas
de gaulle hongos a no se puede proteger
algo que no se conoce por esa razón
hacemos esta clasificación sistemática
que nos permite conocer los detalles de
especies únicas de corongo ssa y así
podemos cuidarlas
entre las especies más estudiadas por
los científicos algunas están
particularmente amenazadas como por
ejemplo el pangolín sus escamas son muy
deseadas por el mercado asiático por sus
supuestas virtudes medicinales este fue
rescatado ayer estaba en manos de
cazadores furtivos
muerto de hambre se precipita sobre las
termitas
alimento éste pangolín porque hace días
no comida tras días de cautiverio a
manos de cazadores
of captivity with fotos y nietos
necesita comer para volver a estar
fuerte
[Música]
un trabajo de protección e investigación
que toma tiempo y cuesta
pero afortunadamente el parque pudo
contar con una bendición
[Música]
esta noche un hombre discute con algunos
empleados frente al agua
se trata de greg por un millonario
norteamericano hizo su fortuna con
software nexus antes de enamorarse de
corongo sa e invertir masivamente con su
fundación hasta 3 millones de euros al
año
hay mejor lugar para invertir el dinero
que aquí
cuidando el ecosistema y apoyando
personas desconocidas quien no gastaría
su dinero en esta causa
hoy en día el parque es modelo en
materia de protección animal
próxima etapa reintroducir rinocerontes
una de las especies faltantes los leones
están presentes su cantidad pasó de 10 a
200 durante estos 20 últimos años